comienza oficialmente este foro
económico mundial en Suiza y el informe
que se ha llevado a todas las miradas el
día de hoy es el que entrega oxfam
internacional está ong sin ánimo de
lucro que hace énfasis en la desigualdad
y que entrega su informe anualmente en
el marco de este evento para este año
los entre los hallazgos está que el 1%
de la población se quedó con la mitad de
la riqueza generada entre 2020 y 2022 es
decir después de la pandemia y el 99%
restante de la población se quedó con el
otro 50% de esos 42 billones de dólares
en fortuna que se han generado por eso
hace
énfasis en Solicitar a los diferentes
gobiernos que trabajen en imponer
nuevos exámenes a las personas con más
altos recursos específicamente hablan de
un 5% de gravamen para los
multimillonarios y dicen que con esto al
menos dos mil personas dos mil millones
de personas podrían salir de la pobreza
en los próximos años también ha pedido a
gobiernos que no se sigan concentrando
en Elevar los impuestos como el impuesto
al valor agregado o IVA sino que se
concentre en las personas más
privilegiadas